[music playing]
RCHARD DOLAN: The Flatwoods
monster case, this
occurred on September 12, 1952.
[thunder]
This whole thing
happened at dusk,
and there were a number
of young people going off
into the woods, and saw some
kind of fiery glowing object
that descended or came down.
Two of the boys, Ed and
Freddy, grabbed their mother,
whose name is Kathleen May, and
she came back with the group
to see this thing, what they
described as a creature.
It's very tall.
It's got eyes that are glowing
red, and it scares them.
Project Blue Book
still in the early years.
And it was reported
to the Air Force
because there was
something in the sky.
RCHARD DOLAN: Investigators who
went there after the sighting
stated that there was an unusual
smell or odor in that area,
and it was said that
the trees in the area
were singed at the top.
There were investigators
who said that branches
actually were broken.
Now, that's very
interesting that branches
were broken by something
that evidently came down.
This is one of the instances
in which Project Blue Book
was genuinely actively
doing serious investigations
at that time.
I do recall seeing
the May family sketches.
They weren't extremely
detailed, but they were similar.
The family members all
drew the same thing,
which was interesting.
The official
explanation was that it
was a combination
of a bright meteor
and a delusion, a
psychological case.
Most puzzling case, for my
father thought about that a lot
and really couldn't conclude
anything one way or the other.
[boom]